okay hello everybody the energy
it's just that's literally how they work
they vibrate your bones oh you're right
yeah
okay you can turn the volume down okay
you want to turn it up
[Music]
welcome back to the chordo digital
podcast everybody thanks for being here
it's episode
165 and we have some very special guests
today we've got Peter France in the
building wait sorry oh my God
moving right past Peter we have Jordan
Allen what's up what's up
and of course Matt Karens himself yeah
well I haven't been on the podcast in a
while but Peter clearly has not been on
the podcast for even longer I'm hammered
you don't know what's going fantastic to
have everybody back in the building oh
are you just gonna call me you're just
gonna be on the phone with him
he's um
he's just I'm rolling on the phone
because I got Jake right here and I got
you guys right here so yeah so Peter's
just gonna be taking a call on the whole
podcast he's just like sorry hold on
it's a business well that's occur ring I
have a very special thing that I need to
get off my chest okay get it off baby
great all right so here's the deal guys
I've been living in the great state of
Texas for three years now
um and you know by way of California by
way of Minnesota by before that
Minnesota I was born and raised there me
Nico and Sam and uh one thing we learned
growing up there is you pay attention to
the weather you just you just do it's
something you do because if you don't
you know it can you can put yourself in
some pretty hairy situations if you're
not careful
um because the weather can change on you
pretty quickly
so you know you learn to you learn to
live with it and you learn to deal with
it of course California you know you get
rain but usually the weather tells you
when it's gonna rain and there's been a
lot of rain lately but normally it's
pretty straightforward it's been pretty
hard well people people's people's roofs
are barely leak-proof in some places you
know
um so the weather's so great there
um but one thing I didn't expect moving
out here was uh people's General lack of
observation of what are some
considerable weather conditions really
uh yeah now I I gotta be I got to be
serious for a second here I mean
if you don't like the weather in Texas
just wait 15 minutes and it'll be
different and that is it's either soup
it gets really really hot in the Summers
as everyone knows it's notorious for
that but a lot of things a lot of things
people don't know is it actually gets
quite cold in the winter time and every
year since we've been here there's been
at least one snow ice storm since we've
been here and it seems like nobody has
come to terms with this yet but and I
can't tell if it's just because I've
only lived here
it's either too low or too high there's
a reason I didn't play sports
so I can't I can't tell if prior to 2020
the winters were actually not that bad
and you know people people were just
like whatever so the thing here's the
thing
the the the water pipes aren't insulated
they don't have furnaces in any of the
houses
um so most things a lot of things aren't
even insulated
um and when it gets really cold you have
to do what's called dripping your pipes
which apparently is a normal practice in
Minnesota one does not drip pipes okay
you insulate a pipe that's what you do
you don't drip a pipe because it gets a
little bit cold you you insulate a pipe
and therefore pipe no pipe no freeze
it's a concept pipe no freeze build pipe
below frost line pipe no freeze no it's
like really really dreams stay alive
right and and pipes do freeze every now
and then in Minnesota but it's not like
a regular widespread common occurrence
every time it hits below freezing here
every time it hits below freezing like
there's like a line at the Home Depot
where just people are lined up to get
new PVC pipe and then what do they do
they just replace the PVC pipe and then
move on with their life as if it won't
happen again the next year or even the
next month what are they gonna learn I
don't get get it so I'm sitting here
going guys what's going on you know and
you know we're we're at the grocery
store getting some supplies as the
weather was rolling in prior to the
weather rolling in and people didn't
even know they didn't even know that
like a winter storm was coming and now
it's you know it's been below freezing
for like literally 36 hours
my car is a literal sheet of ice like it
it looks like it it looks like it came
off the set of Frozen like it's got the
it's got the icicles on it my whole the
whole north side of my house broadside
of my house is just covered in a sheet
of rain ice wow so we've been in
literally in an ice storm for the last
two days oh wow wow so so Jake this is
not like a lighting setup you have this
is just the blue but not all of the ice
yeah
right now it was like should I go pink
should I go orange no we're gonna go
Blue today because I get it I can't
understand are you chilly in there you
got a good heater uh well see also
here's the thing okay
let me take out my gum for this because
this is gonna be my real rant okay [__]
real room taking some water too
here I don't know you know maybe native
Texans maybe you can correct me on this
I I don't know what it was like before I
got here but I do have a Texas Almanac
okay and it does tell me the weather
patterns prior to when I lived here and
according to that it's the Farmer's
Almanac it's like the thing that tells
you the weather patterns before you know
it's like known for that
apparently it gets below freezing at
least a few times between November and
March 15th almost consistently every
year
oh so if it does that every year and
every year your pipes burst and then so
here's the thing about the houses Peter
we don't have furnaces okay and in
California you could go okay yeah that
makes sense why would you need a furnace
it like hardly ever gets below 45
degrees in Southern California
but so what they have are called heat
pumps and they're basically it's a unit
on your air conditioning that intakes
the air from the outside and from that
outside air generates heat but it only
works
it only works to when you're when your
air gets when the outside air basically
gets below 40 degrees or like near
freezing the heat pump can't do anything
more it can't produce any more heat so
that means like you literally cannot
heat your house past
65 degrees if you're lucky 60 degrees
yeah and so when it gets really cold
which two like right over Christmas it
got down to 12 degrees at night one
night and wow and and so people like
they just bundle up into their like
coats and they like sit you know we have
a fireplace
but you you bundle up and you just have
to deal with it because nobody thought
to put in furnaces in any of the houses
I mean it makes sense you think of Texas
like that's Western territory yeah it
doesn't get cold there it's it's amazing
see the thing is the desert the desert
actually gets really cool I don't know
if it does see yeah you're a Southern
California boy you don't you don't know
this like the New Mexico gets
ridiculously cold huh Arizona can get
ridiculously cold like you you can't
just go hey guys it's gonna be fine and
apparently this is what people have been
doing here since
I don't know when
I don't get bundling up like they're
freaking uh Little House on the Prairie
situation just and so I just thought you
know
coming from earlier hey maybe people
would have gotten used to this and
thought hey you know let us think a year
in the future no and consider of putting
our water pipes underneath the ground
Instagram consider putting in a gas
furnace in a house so that way when it
does get cold which it will your house
isn't freezing and your pipes don't
freeze yeah everyone's like no it's not
that big of a deal but tomorrow's not
guaranteed you know so I'm not that's
true
but for now
anyway that's my rant you know I'm sure
there'll be a lot of people in the
comments that are like hey have you
thought about this or hey you know you
didn't think about that please I'm open
to trying to understand the rationale
here well I'm just failing to understand
it Jake if you had if I could write you
a blank check that was devoted to fixing
this problem what would you do
I would well I mean like as a problem
for Humanity or as a problem for me for
Texas
all of Texas or all of Texas I would
start I would start a construction
company that specializes in using
winterizing techniques
I'd go up to Wisconsin and I'd go give
me your best Carpenters let's go we're
gonna create a new company we're gonna
use Northern techniques to actually
create properties down here with people
that know how to build things that are
going built to withstand the accurate
weather conditions that we are actually
experiencing consistently and then we'll
form a company and then people can hire
us to make homes that don't break in the
wintertime wow okay here's another idea
what if you filled the the sprinkler
line with gasoline oh and uh just had
them running full blast all day every
day and just just strike the lighter and
so you just have big fires around every
neighborhood surrounding you would
equalize Yeah by fire it's not a bad
idea there's no burn ban there the burn
ban is off right now so to
your water lines though yeah I mean
they're unfreezing so yeah right so we
will find the negative thawing out the
water lines but so check this out okay
check this out you you have you right
now we're dripping our pipes so our
pipes don't freeze right so you send a
little trickle drip through your pipes
why did you put it in the air quotes
though
because I'm I don't know we're dripping
our pipes I don't know if a lot of
people know what that means
until I moved to the South because I'm a
northern boy but anyways
what if it gets below 15 degrees I'm
literally just kind of empty my wall I'm
gonna CL I'm gonna take my water pipes
and I'm gonna clear them out so they
don't freeze and then like you literally
just don't have water
I mean you have water like you you put
it in five gallon you know we have one
of those little water dispensers
with the five gallon jug but um
you know this kind of reminds me a
little bit of how California has been
dealing with rain uh which is incredibly
poorly
um I'm a Florida man so we the rain is
rain all the time it's always raining in
Florida
um and it's kind of it's kind of like
Texas where it's like okay well it's one
thing 15 minutes from now it's not
enough it's another thing you know so it
doesn't rain all the time but you know
it's it's a consistent thing right it is
a swamp and one thing that I was shocked
in living here I I've never experienced
so much rain here that I that I have you
know over the past couple of months when
it's been raining like crazy like
record-breaking amounts of rain right
and I realized that uh there's one key
thing
uh that that just the infrastructure in
La doesn't really have and that's like
proper uh lit up markers on the road yes
so it doesn't have reflective tape on
the actual dividers like the lane
dividers
and you don't realize until it is wet at
night and you cannot see the lanes you
don't know what you're like what Lane
you're in ever yeah so it's like
about that when I lived there
how do people just make flings on there
line dividers yeah and on top of that
it's like I'm not replacing my wiper
blades ever I'm not going to go to the
effort to do that that's true so they
need to make it extra clear where the
lanes are because I can't see a goddamn
thing yeah there's already a lot of
water on the windshield another thing is
that Florida when it rains it just is a
free car wash
um whereas here it rains and your car is
instantly dirty
it actually gets worse yeah I like I
actually got a car wash and then it
rained the next day and my car was just
filthy immediately so yeah that's
awesome too cool in San Francisco
flooded did you guys see those videos it
was like five feet of water just in the
Streets of San Francisco because they
didn't have I don't know the right
drainage I didn't really see it no and
then there were people there were like
um Vigilantes going out with rakes like
pulling [__] out of gutters so it could
like that you gave them the term
Vigilantes
Samaritans I don't know degunking the
they're all dressing up in costumes
there were people kayaking around and
stuff it looks kind of fun honestly it's
what happened when I was in um I was in
I was off on this island off the coast
of Cancun called Isla mojeres it's a
beautiful island and um I was there for
my brother's Friend's Wedding is that
where you got food poisoning yes yeah
there's a video there's a vlog on it I
remember that yeah it's like a 2016 or
2017 vlog
but anyways we were there and it started
pouring and the entire Island like
flooded
um the dead there's like a down there's
like a Main Street you know where all
the restaurants and where people go at
night party and whatever that whole
street flooded out and I'd never seen
anything like that
um but apparently uh they had that
problem in San Fran as well it's pretty
crazy yeah yeah I mean I know it's not
nearly as bad obviously but I mean just
even right outside the studio it's
absolutely night of rain and it's like
Bessie's I have to wear my besties in
order to park and get here without
destroying a pair of shoes did you ever
see that video that we did where I got
the raft out and I rafted down the
street that clip makes it sway into any
compilation of corridor content ever
edited
is so funny just the visual image you
paddling
water it was a good time we had been
joking about that for months and then we
finally got the opportunity to do it and
I was so glad because that's great we
literally floated the raft down the
street yeah worth all the pennies you
spent on that raft yes but anyways
speaking of corridor content oh speaking
of speaking of all the good things the
reason why you all are here isn't to
talk about the weather okay or to hear
me gripe about the way that houses are
built what we're really all here for
is to talk about just what what the hell
have we done what literally what have we
done specifically YouTube done why did
we do this in a way we are talking about
the temperature we're talking about the
temperature of like of of the medium of
mobile games and how hot it's gotten it
is never been hotter it's never been
hotter I guess so I think you I think
you guys nailed it thank you bro so so
Jake I just saw this on on Discord you
haven't seen you you like had just seen
anything so for those of you who are
just listening in on this for the first
time over the last week or so Jordan and
Matt sat set out on a journey to make a
uh mobile game ad for Peter's new game
um I don't know if it was for the game
it was curated specifically for the game
it did have the title of the game in it
yeah exactly exactly Peter Francis
turns out that's all you need to connect
illegally
[Laughter]
like the thing is I've just been
obsessed with these things I don't know
what it is like it started like really
popping up a couple of years ago
um and we have some sick stats for you
that I'll break down later because it is
kind of insane what this industry has
done and the growth it's had over the
course of like a couple of years but you
start to see all of these insane uh game
ads mobile game ads uh and I started
seeing them on Instagram and when uh
Facebook reminds me that it's somebody's
birthday and I go on Facebook dust off
the cobwebs
um you see all these these ads and
they're insane they're all just like
some of the craziest pieces of marketing
you've ever seen in your life they're
kind of amazing yeah and you wonder yeah
yeah they're like they're pretty highly
produced
um but but they just had they just intro
their ads with some of the most like
horrendous things you've ever seen like
shock value stuff big stinky booty girls
and and Pregnant weird pregnancy things
and yeah lots of smells yeah it's like
they they so we've all seen these I mean
you've been on YouTube that on Instagram
you see the ad and it's like clearly a
robotic AI translation of English and
it's then the most just like what would
be the equivalent of like pornographic
imagery in the sense of of like it it
immediately hits your Reptilian Brain
yeah yes it does it's it's the low brain
that the rest of your brain is built on
that is a great way to put it and it's
just like lowest common denominator
themes of sex you know defecation uh
like violence pregnancy honestly zombies
are in there too yeah
structured on just the most
cringy of the cringiest of like human
emotions served up on an unashamed
platter yep and for years Matt has been
intrigued by these videos
I have been so yeah so that's the thing
is like over the course of these like
years I've been just collecting data
I've been I've been like screen capping
yeah I've been screen capping these
mobile games putting them in my secret
folders it's for work Mom it's for work
I swear
um and I guess yeah I guess the thing is
like we were trying to figure out how to
make it an actual Corridor video because
like you know making it a crew video is
like you got to get the right framing
device around it you have to make it
give it a story you know you can't just
make some weird emotions if it's
something weird yeah there was one point
where we're just like well maybe we'll
just react to them but then it's like
well we're also visual effects artists
we gotta make the dang thing too that
was yeah that was the thing that you
made one yeah we gotta do it ourselves
right I mean when we first set up to
make the actual idea after like a lot of
discussion internally it was yeah just
to react to yeah and like Matt and I
were chatting about it and it just
didn't feel right it felt like it was
just lacking in something and we you
know we were having another larger
conversation on like what do we like
because if we react to the mobile games
why would you want to listen to us
reacting to mobile games like what
Authority do we have in the space
there's not really any real reason yeah
um but what can we do that a lot of
other creators can do is actually go out
and make our own using all the tropes we
possibly can blending it up together in
This Disaster and surprising you with it
yeah yeah as a gift yeah and that's
that's when the light bulb really went
off where it's like oh wait a second
Peter France is making a video game so
had you been making this before you
brought it to me or was it oh yeah
definitely yeah well no not not the
mobile game ad itself but we were like
just kind of conceptualizing trying to
figure it out and then we were like well
okay if we can if we can make a game ad
that sells Peter's game yeah you know
that's that's the perfect frame
or anything like that but you know what
I think uh I think you're marketing
strategy if we push this on tick tock
tick tock will for sure yeah right yeah
they don't care they don't care we'll
try Texas no shame yeah yeah if you guys
just head on over to check out the crew
video you'll kind of know the the
context of all this but yeah that didn't
get approved we'll talk about that a
little bit more later but I do want to
know like more about the game itself
yeah yeah how long have you been working
on it like it's a VR game right yeah
yeah it's a VR game it's uh it's called
heart shot and uh here you want the you
want the little pitch yeah baby okay
elevator pitch so imagine it's 19.99.
you're playing a game in VR that is
similar to you know familiar with Time
Crisis where you like pull out the blue
or red gun and you shoot at the screen
and they're like bad guys I used to have
an arcade version of it in the studio oh
yeah it's ready yeah there was a cabinet
here oh nice
um yeah but anyway so it's in that style
so it's in the old like retro uh PS1
like pixelated Graphics style which also
is like secretly helps with performance
a lot
so we like gives you that Jank buffer
yeah the Jank is the style and also
helps with you know the form
um so yeah uh you start out as like this
action hero spy person and you're
infiltrating this castle base you know
shooting people up explosions blah blah
blah very cartoonish violence I don't
want to be actually like gruesome and
violent like we don't need that but very
very um silly glossy violence and uh
anyways so you're going through this
base you're terminating bad guys silence
pistol explosions etc etc and you turn a
corner and you bump into one of these uh
goons and they drop their gun you drop
your gun and you're like oh my God this
is so sorry this is so awkward they're
like oh my God I'm so sorry you start
picking up your guns and then you like
Hawk Eyes with this person and something
happens and it's beautiful a little hard
chat start popping up between you two
and you fall in love with this person oh
and it's like hey do you want to like
get out of here as explosions are like
going up in the distance it's like hey
do you want to get out of here and like
go get some sushi uh or something like
that and so it basically it turns from
an action game into a dating simulator
um and then it goes back and forth
throughout the course of the game
between action and like silly dating Sam
which honestly is like kind of along the
lines of what you guys made like it's
not going to be anywhere near as raunchy
but it's gonna be like you're at the
carnival and it's like you throw in the
pins to try and win your date a teddy
bear or whatever and then there are
various like emotional Stakes throughout
the story of your relationship being
tested as you're both pulled in
different directions by your employers
um but yeah it's it's kind of weaves in
between like traditional action game and
and rom-com I think it's gonna be pretty
fun that's awesome it's very cool yeah
so you're hitting on the bass emotions
of love and violence exactly yeah and
everybody's favorite things I mean yeah
you said hearts hearts go off when when
the gremlin that sounds really really
fun man makes me want to play VR I'm not
a big VR guy yeah but I I that make that
sounds like a game that I want to play
yeah thank you yeah yeah I would love uh
at some point to just bring it into the
studio and have everybody yeah no that's
a great idea you should at least do it
for a crew cuts episode that'd be fun
that would be super what made you want
to uh make up the argument in the first
place well I during the pandemic I got a
VR headset because I was what else am I
going to do with my time
um and yeah I got it it was when
Half-Life Alex came out which is an
amazing virtual reality game by Valve
who did like Half-Life and portal and
it's one of my favorite video games in
general it's yeah absolutely incredible
I keep replaying it it feels like you're
participating in a movie yeah right like
a really well set dressed and acted and
everything movie
um and I was really inspired by that and
a couple years ago when I was working
here full-time Nico was like hey you
should learn unreal for virtual
production I was like okay uh I'm Gonna
Learn unreal for virtual production but
also on the side I'm gonna learn it for
game development too because I love
video games I've always wanted to make a
video game but it's you know large
barrier to entry but hey if I have an
opportunity to learn it
um get paid to do it why not you know so
I spent the next few months learning it
and I made some crappy games I made a
Smash Brothers clone which was super
janky that was not a crappy game okay
game that I've ever been the champion of
that was I can't believe that worked out
like that it was amazing that was that
was a very glee-filled moment yeah it
couldn't have we couldn't have written
it
um but yeah so I worked on some other
stuff and then I started playing around
with virtual reality and unreal and just
trying to wrap my head around those
mechanics and as time went on I got a
little bit better at it and I was like
[__] I could make it anybody could make
a game if you just spend enough time
doing it and uh then two years later I
uh I have a pretty fun little demo uh
and so over these next couple months I'm
going to polish that until Kingdom Come
and I'm gonna put it up for Early Access
on Steam and so you guys and any of the
viewers can play it it's gonna be super
fun the mechanics are really really
polished at this point the animation is
like Yeah from what I've seen like the
reloads and all the little uh the little
wiggle bone animations yeah on your
posts on Instagram like how I keep up
with it thanks we just want it to like a
lot of games in general and VR games
require a a certain amount of technical
skill for it to be fun where like a lot
of the time a lot of the time I'll like
put a friend into VR for the first time
and they'll be like bumbling around and
dropping magazines and stuff like that
it's just not fun and we want it to be
fun like right out of the box and so
there are crazy things you can do like
if you release your clip and flick your
hand up at the same time it throws your
clip at the enemy and like staggers them
like John Wick style we want the game to
be like a John Wick simulator
magazine Peter it's not a clip
it's okay I thought it's fine I thought
it was a clip not a magazine no no a
clip is the thing that they used to put
into M1 garance you know like when the
when the rounds are actually clipped
together
and you're dropping it in that's that's
actually a clip okay yeah magazine yeah
I knew that for sure okay but can we
just like be the people here to decide
once and for all that a clip is also a
magazine
within our world right here in this
podcast room yeah it is
I'm just kidding you crap that sounds
awesome man I'm really excited for that
and we should totally do something with
it like play it in a video or yeah do
something
yeah more with it and and get it I
wanted to get out to as many people as
possible so however we can help with
that yeah I appreciate that yeah and
that was the thinking behind this too is
like we're in a situation a little bit
yeah and it's original form of this idea
and its original form of this idea it
was gonna be a render challenge where we
make three different mobile game ads and
then we just show them and it's like ah
you made this one that's gross ooh gross
and it didn't feel like it had the same
life behind I mean once once the idea
floated to make it with real world think
Sam got so excited he's like we're
making this we're doing it right now and
we got all excited and keeping you in
the dark like we really kept Peter in
the dark on this one yeah
sure yeah had no idea what was happening
Instagram yeah we basically just we we
called Peter up you know we're thinking
like okay so we have a solid idea of how
we're gonna do this you know we we want
to get the data right we want to we want
to actually run this ad somewhere and
get the data and prove that it actually
can be more effective than a regular you
know cinematic Gameplay trailer right
um so you know so we call Peter we're
like okay Peter we have this idea we're
going to make an ad for you this was
that's all you knew right you guys on
the phone were so genuine well we were
we were genuine there was a zero mention
of booties of course nothing it needs to
be it needs to be duly noted here how
good of a sport Peter was with this okay
I don't think this has been fully
extrapolated this is his game that he's
been working on for two years three
years and and and we call him up out of
the blue and we say Peter we want to
make a game ad for your game which when
in context it sounds like oh this is
gonna be dope like these guys are gonna
make this I was sending over gameplay
and everything yeah I'm gonna send them
over the cinematic trailer so they know
what it's like and the whole time Matt
and Jordan are over there snickering
about how they're gonna make
Jake hold on first of all we didn't make
him a game at Matt cut him together
we did win two games a normal one but
what was funny was on the call with
Peter as we were like pitching him we
want to you know make this like a great
way to promote the game like we love it
this than the other and he's on the
phone and he's like just so you guys
know like you can make it a little silly
yeah because we were being so serious
with our presentation so he's like and
we were dying at that point I was like
oh my gosh that's the green line we
literally sorry we were like holding
back tears because it was so funny
hearing you say you guys are you guys
yeah we'll make it a little silly okay
all right with your blessing I had a
feeling there was something that I
wasn't like that you guys had up your
sleeve I didn't know it was gonna be
that insane yeah which honestly it's
like I I don't care it's hilarious like
I'm not actually bothered by any of them
yes but honestly Peter the thing that
you were the best sport about is the
fact that you just willingly handed us
the keys yeah to your Instagram account
control of your Instagram account for
like three or four days I should
probably change the password yeah you
definitely should yeah you should and
you just never went on it you just you
just trusted it you didn't see it
guys put that video up I was on my main
Instagram account and I saw about two
seconds of just a booty getting smacked
a little bit and I was like I'm not
supposed to see this
respect you've been going but like your
first instinct was not like I'm not
supposed to see this it was like I'm not
supposed to see this this isn't suitable
content for this platform yeah is what
you really thought that's right yeah
yeah I was like what is this
but uh as we were doing the presentation
like Peter I I me and Matt both as we
were like presenting it we showed it
genuinely we're so concerned that you
were upset yeah I remember like like
vibrating a little bit I was like oh no
I think I think we went too far yeah and
thank you for giving me the Peace of
Mind at the end going no no it's I like
I think it's great you want to repost it
back up yeah yeah but man but it
genuinely made us think that he was yeah
the test was to see if because the whole
thing where this idea spawned from was
you see all these absurd mobile games
they're nothing like the game at all so
if we make one that's nothing like the
game at all is it still actually
effective in converting people to the
game itself because why else would they
do it
well I mean we found that I mean Matt
will will give you the numbers but maybe
the numbers all right we have found that
that is totally the case and it's like a
matter of there's so much content it's
so oversaturated just get noticed get
noticed and get clicked
if you retain even five percent of the
people who download the game that's five
percent more than you would have gotten
just being boring yeah and it's like
again hit the reptile brain move right
past the thinking brain yep and in
writing this that was the hardest thing
we sat in this room for an hour and a
half trying to turn off our thinking
brain yeah it gets big I don't know and
eventually we walk on booty cheeks these
things happen
let's talk about the numbers and then
we'll talk about how and then we'll talk
about another thing yeah let's talk
about the numbers what were the numbers
because yeah the crazy thing is now
first of all I just want to give you an
idea of what the mobile game Market is
like like last year just last year and
this we mentioned this in the video too
but I just want to emphasize that the
mobile game Market in itself last year
uh generated 92 billion dollars in
revenue and the the PC gaming Market
made I believe 38 billion wow and the
console made 40 billion 40 something
billion that's CS5 PS4 that's all the
consoles Nintendo and PC still comes
under
Mobile gaming Market Revenue
for mobile game ads that's nuts
it's insane you're talking about like
like Jewel matching yeah that's all it
is it's just like Jewel matching yeah
and they've also figured out this way in
their marketing to like have it's sort
of like a loophole that they've uh
created for themselves almost where it's
like it's not technically false
advertising because there is at least an
element of what they've shown in their
in all their ads in the game but it's
like in level like 99 yeah right they
push it all the way back to the end but
technically legally it's still in the
game so it's like a market like
something like point five percent of
people will get to it yeah so geez
they're coming is clicking on these ads
dude it turns out is it kids it must be
I've got a fun anecdote about over 50
women that's one thing yeah so which is
interesting my mother-in-law okay there
we go
literally this woman I love her to death
but oh my God you guys she she's been in
California at her other daughter's house
for the last couple months because she
goes there to spend time with her and
other than that she she lives with us
and so Wendy had called her to just ask
her how she was doing and what she was
doing that day
and she she's like what are you doing
today mom and her mom was like oh I got
uh I've got to like feed the chickens
and like do the do this thing and that
thing and when he was confused like you
know do you have they got chickens
what's going on like she was talking
about what she had to do in Heyday
that's right yeah Heyday baby that's the
retention I'm talking about she was like
this is what I have to do today I have
to complete these Heyday tasks yeah and
you wonder like is it it's the feeling
of accomplishment I mean clearly that
would make you feel like hey I did like
I did three four or five things today
sure yeah and it was easy and I got like
that dopamine head of like
accomplishment accomplishment
accomplishment and it's like you just
gotta rope them in keep the ones that
stay and then slowly add in these pay
walls that hey I've already invested
yeah it's like uh
um the sunk cost fallacy right like I've
already put in this much money yeah I I
keep I want to keep going but I have to
just oh it's three bucks three bucks and
that happens with a hundred thousand
people it's like all of a sudden you're
starting to rake in Crazy amounts of
money wow you know it's it's pretty
smart stuff but yeah
in that sense
but is it also just slowly driving our
entire species off of a cliff oh it's
for sure
it's more a lead definitely you know
yeah
yeah morally
defecate
deficients
aren't there like some kind of marmots
or prairie dogs that just all run off a
cliff together that's kind of what
mobile games
started in the right direction yeah I
just I kind of view it as like and this
might be a terrible analogy here but I
view it as like in Vegas the console
games and the PC games those are the
table games that's Blackjack that's you
know uh all those other classic games
then you've got the slots and the slots
are a different Beast altogether that's
all about getting you addicted running
off your brain and just hoping yeah
it looks like a slot machine yeah yeah
that's mobile games man they're like
they're trying to turn your brain off
and just keep churning basically our
slot machines I mean they use the same
color patterns mechanics like a dick
random chance of victory yeah 100 and
it's like they have that dialed into
where you'll win just enough to keep you
coming back but not enough to where you
get bored like they it's pretty messed
up
don't care at all about the art of the
game to the point where those are the
ads is just perfectly you know
illustrating how little care there is
and for someone who's poured his heart
into this thing and like genuinely cares
about it it's really funny
I thought it was really funny to tell
your name like that I don't really care
about does it work oh yeah yeah let's
hear the numbers let's talk stats man
let's talk numbers here let's talk
numbers I got a screen recording here
because all will be forgiven if you
actually brought people to Peter's game
that's true wait do we I will do we save
it did we say if it works on this
podcast or we just anyone this is coming
this will be out by it's in the video
yeah I'm just saying like should they
just go watch the video and check it out
for yourself
fine they've already seen this is the
this is the this is the uh debrief come
on you know
the funnel direction is
video lands here all right so
website so so ideally you watch the
video as a web as a court or digital
member of course of course and you
watched it on quarter digital yes you
all did guys yeah oh my God can I just
say this is why you listen to the
podcast because I'm about to drop some
information right we submitted LG for
Smart TV last week we submitted Samsung
for Smart TV today we're submitting
apple on Friday and we're submitting
Android next Friday wait we're gonna
have apps it's the best news ever we're
gonna have TV smart TV apps and these
they look cool they look
dude I'm so excited about that I know so
good is a high compliment coming from
Jake Jake has high standards for these
things I do and they look really good
and I'm so excited so anyways
yeah I can't wait to use that yeah
that's this is awesome it's great to I I
know my parents were like asking for it
for a while
roku's like a little bit more
complicated so don't worry Roku people
I'm a Roku guy too we're gonna do Roku
just
you're gonna have to download it
on your smart TV first I'm sorry sorry
what about what about like PS5 PS4 PS5
yes
yes and Xbox two or is that on the way
Xbox I gotta ask Scott but PS4 and PS5
we have a call with them
like on Friday
so that's awesome yes what about VR can
we have like a Minority Report thing
I mean if you want to build it build oh
scan the office
we were talking about like doing a
virtual tour in VR like the universal
version yeah wouldn't that be hilarious
do like the janky version but in VR oh
my God and we can like with our scans we
can stage certain things in certain
rooms yeah memories and when we can have
like a project going on and it'll
actually just be a casino where we'll
get people slightly addicted to coming
in
definitely and like every time you open
the door you get 10 subscribers to your
virtual social media profile
oh boy oh God
but uh back to these numbers
because the first thing that you know
you probably are all aware if you've
seen the video
um it didn't work
in terms of like actually being an ad
that we could run uh Instagram said nope
yeah when we say it didn't work no way
when we say didn't work we mean just in
getting approved like Instagram shut
down it even being an ad it was
Instagram refused as an actual ad for
sexual content so for child oh child
endangerments violence towards children
the tiger yeah there's the tiger thing
that happens
um
rejected every time I tried to do it
like four different times and you cut
things out right you cut certain things
that you thought oh this must be yeah I
actually I went through the trouble of
cutting out certain elements of it to
try it again enough of Instagram to
destroy a work of art I know what's
crazy is it is no worse than and what is
already running yeah that's what drives
me nuts it really isn't I wonder how
they get that stuff through
watching an ad
I skip it but it's a six second ad and
the first six seconds start with some
character some 3D character
who looks like a knight
just sunken into the bosom of some you
know that girl yeah I know like how is
that I've seen that one how is that a
person I skip and I don't know what
happens after that but I I'm just how is
that approved exactly no it made it
enraged me I was genuinely pissed off
about it because it like doesn't make
sense why ours you know it's like it's I
guess the mobile game industry it's a
freaking 100 billion dollar industry man
so I guess money moves baby a year so
you know that I guess they probably also
have that dialed into such a degree oh
in terms of what you can and can't get
away with yeah just to the edge just to
the edge yeah I have no idea where that
edge is we did not find it clearly like
the the incest birth thing that probably
was the incest birth proposal yeah
it was specific
child but also a man who might be
unrelated I don't actually know the Lord
did he propose to her he did propose to
her yeah he took a knee okay
I like to believe that he has like a
home gym inside her body yeah
he looked like one of those six-year-old
guys who's on the keto diet every day
you know yeah but uh I mean Matt did
post it on the heart shot page so we do
have some numbers that would illustrate
how it would perform
on a smaller scale no on a yeah and on a
scale that these are all your followers
your real followers uh saw both of these
ads the kind of crowd you're in real
life
um and uh so now our I'm actually I'm
proud of this little edit for the
Cinematic version oh it's great it's a
fun little edit I wish I had some of the
other story beats in there too but you
know we'll we'll see if we can maybe
squeeze some of those into it'd be fun
to get some of the romance uh stuff in
there um but either way yeah this is
like a fun little cinematic just kind of
uh to like a really cool beat
um and uh yeah it just basically shows
what the game is you know no uh no no
lies or deceit here uh and what we got
is five comments and eight shares all
right on that okay so it's a respectable
number
um but then we go to our more
unconventional the Creator you know
creatively free
throwing internally as the Abominations
yeah Jake coined it uh I like to say the
Abomination because of the butt it's
good thank you very much um now this one
has 24 comments and 183 shares look at
that that's 1800 increase
in comments they don't lie guys that
stuff works man you know and it's I've
been making peace with myself this
entire process each night saying it's
not us it's not our fault this is the
way the world is yeah right we're
feeding the Beast that exists
Peter deserves that attention because
his game is worth it thank you and so
this was a fight for our boy all right
that's the other days we can pull a at
least we can pull a a fast one on him
when they actually get to the game and
find out how good it is exactly and we
had a long discussion about the ending
of that ad too and we wanted to make
sure that Peter France was eternally
tied to the advice Peter Francis
the game yeah he has no no choice
he was the same did you even use the
same logo font
this game does do well
um and someone decides to sue me for
false advertising I think they'd win no
no no because here's the loophole as
long as there is something you never
admit never admit fault Peter in a legal
case here's the thing okay as long as
there is something from the ad in the
game we're good and so Peter graciously
to include our ad on the screen of one
of the arcade games in the game or
somewhere yeah yeah and now it's in the
game baby for you guys to find that I I
really am going to do yeah that's so fun
dude freaking arcade game like I sent
him the files he has everything he needs
to put it in like the like the dystopian
display window you know yeah yeah uh-huh
in an arcade
[Music]
you have Ryan Gosling looking at it all
Stone Face yes yeah not saying a word
but saying everything exactly all at the
same time yeah I'll say this one other
thing when this other little stat for
you
um now Peter's Peter's a heart shot uh
Instagram which is the one we use the
official game Instagram not Peter's
actual account
um so this this heart shot Instagram it
doesn't have a whole lot of followers
um and if you'd like to be so gracious
is to follow a heart shot uh and it's at
heart shot game on Instagram now it only
it only has 100. it only has 1 300 uh
followers okay that's a lot dude yeah
don't say only one though
you ready are you ready are you watching
the followers check it out now refresh
and you know why he did that because of
the ad he did it that was because
so that's because of you guys you're
welcome you lost 20 when we posted it
but now you got one yeah whatever so 19.
weed out the week you know send them
home oh did he the ones
my point in what I was saying
is that I was as soon as we posted the
uh more offensive mobile game ad uh his
followers started dropping immediately
it's so scary he lost like 20 followers
in like a couple of hours
you know people just can't handle it
that's yeah but you know what happens
it's the tide pulling back before the
next wave exactly that's what that is
and that's the thing that's the week
being cold and then the new wave of
people that you're going to be getting
back yeah yeah
no it's I mean any uh all of the greats
were not regarded during their time
thank God they were not revered it's
exactly after the after the facts uh
the thing is Peter it's a great page it
has a lot of great updates on what
you've been doing and fun little pieces
of content in there so you know I'll
smash that like button all over this you
know I think I'm gonna delete those and
hire you guys full time okay I guess it
because it sounds great no sick thanks
guys thank you awesome that was actually
in the contract that you signed by the
way so you know yeah so that's part of
the deal yeah we have 10 of All rights
yeah
those are good thank you that's okay
that's okay you did it you did about the
contract baby I agree to that with so
many people so it's just gonna be split
evenly so you now have like negative 23
percent of your game lots of debt uh
yeah you said though and you don't have
to but you you mentioned that you might
make that that archived post live again
though well I did the heart asked me to
for some reason I didn't even read the
whole text I was just like okay y'all on
our camera I was it was just for the
video right right the crew video is now
yeah I haven't even seen the crew video
yet so I'm very excited to see it yeah
but um I was thinking what if we take
okay so the structure of this ad is it
starts as big stinky big stinky right
and then it goes into don't you hate it
when that ad isn't the real game and the
game's the real game and then there's
like the gameplay but then you do it
again and it's like don't you hate when
the real gameplay isn't the real
gameplay here's the real gameplay and
then we do the actual trailer that's
actually such a great idea that's good
you're getting the attention you're
giving them the real game wait we don't
even know we don't even have to film a
new one we just do the other a new uh AI
voice AI voice yeah and then attached
yeah that's genius that's good there you
go this guy think's big so don't you
hate it when the real game is not the
real game
this is the real game and then you do it
a fourth time and it's just a black
screen I love it I love it Peter they're
just looking at themselves in the
reflection like oh Life's a game
artist and you're losing and you're a
loser get off your phone I can put that
together for you Peter if that's
something you really want that I love
that I'm totally down yeah yeah that
that too Jake that don't you hate it
when the game's on a game is another
Trope that is just abundant it's it's
crazy to me how many times I started
seeing ads where the guy would come down
and it would be his voice and he'd be
like hey don't you hate it when the
game's on the game this is the game and
it's not the game that's also alive but
then you started getting enhanced
versions of that where their voice
wasn't even their voice and it didn't
match their mouth right and they were
saying don't you hate it when the game's
not the game weird so it was getting
crazier and crazier so we're like we
need to include that as well dude
there's a there's another layer deep I
think I showed you this it's probably
out in the video but uh there there is
an apology video from the the CG
characters apologizing that the game
wasn't the game enough that's amazing it
wasn't enough of the actual game and
they were like we're sorry we'll give
you a free promo card code because our
game was not the game that's incredible
yeah they like apologize you know what I
bet that was an ad too
exactly because it gives you free [__]
yeah wow yeah anytime they do have a
real person on though it's always
someone who's very like punchable like
they're they're upsetting to look at
yeah and so we did a poll on corridor's
Instagram I don't know if you know this
I I saw it who has a more punchable face
I voted but I'm not gonna say fruit that
I respect that yeah it was neck and neck
it was I went by a slim 76 yes
I
have this underlying this may just be my
own self-doubt but I have this
underlying theory that that a lot of
people in the corridor audience want to
punch me so I don't think that's true at
all
look at his face give me your most
punchable face oh um I did I did a smile
that people just hated
I was about to get up for my chair
honestly just okay okay yeah yeah
magical face your most punchable face
he's got like a pretty good boy that's
that's that's
fell in love with that face
right there sorry yeah oh man you got a
pretty good punchable face Jake but our
goal was you know to to figure it out
because I listen to a lot of SoundCloud
rappers
but yeah whoever won that contest was
going to be the face that comes down
uh just to further enhance how upsetting
the commercial was sure I like that you
just told about it that's that's good
Market that's marketing research yeah or
by the book yeah by the book 100 so
yeah I gotta live with that oh yeah
Peter when are you gonna release this
game my friend oh boy well thank you
guys for uh being so gracious with your
time and energy and helping me promote
my game yeah yeah man uh we genuinely
think it's gonna be really cool I can't
wait to play it seriously thanks yeah
it's I think it's gonna be really fun I
know it's really fun yeah it's gotten to
the point where sometimes I'll be play
testing and then I'll just keep playing
oh that's great that's sweet dude and
then I I forget that I'm supposed to be
play testing because I'm just having a
good time playing around with mechanics
like we have a force grab thing where
you can um like if somebody's attacking
you you can grab a bottle from a table
over there and throw it at them and like
make some stagger for a second yeah it's
time to reload or whatever yeah there's
also there's another mechanic that is
like that's why I made sure to put it in
the trailer as like a highlight moment
is this like gun rotating gun arm thing
where it's like you can switch your guns
that are just attached to your arm in
this little cylinder yeah it's like VR
is so immersive why have menus yeah
exactly why have a weapon switching menu
just make it a gauntlet yeah
kicks ass it's really cool yes it's
pretty fun are there any like big
features that you want to add that
you're not sure you'll have the
bandwidth or like capability at this
point of adding well the big one right
now is right now it's only PC VR so it's
not the initial Early Access release
isn't going to be for Oculus Standalone
you can still play it on your Oculus
connected to a computer but like no
Standalone so that's going to be the big
thing is once it's out converting it to
the Oculus Standalone which is it
doesn't have as much computing power and
stuff like that so you gotta kind of
pair it down a little bit but honestly
since it's in this like cheesy
retrographic style I don't think it's
going to be too bad heck yeah but uh you
know I always say that and then it is
how big is like your team or is it
it is three people it's me um I'm doing
the coding and a lot of the art and
assets uh my roommate and business
partner Riley is who you guys love very
well are uh is uh doing a lot of the
level design in the like the block
meshing like a lot of these
um AAA games I've been watching a lot of
like conferences about this kind of
thing and they'll uh they'll do this
thing called The Block mesh where you
basically you just create your level
with simple shapes and cubes no lighting
no textures or anything and then you
play it and make sure it's really fun
just like that and so then when you
throw in the textures and the nice
lighting and the environments and
everything after it makes it extra juicy
because yeah the base gameplay
yeah Riley's doing a lot of that and
then we also have uh Benjamin Squires
who's doing the music who's the same guy
who did the music for scooty dude yeah
so yeah and this is like another like
level to the con that we did on you
because because uh out of necessity I
needed to ask for a lot of assets from
you like a lot of you know game footage
as well as the music so I heard the
music and it slaps it's very cool it
didn't work for a trailer I had to find
my own but you know I got a good idea of
like what the feel of the game was it's
pretty sweet it's great yeah very cool
we pitched uh Benjamin the idea of doing
like
old like using terrible old synthesizers
that they would have used for the 90s
games but then mixing it with
traditional orchestration so you get
this really fun blend and yeah it's
really cool yeah especially the castle
ones thanks I love the castle a little
ones yeah good job yeah oh yeah Benjamin
yeah
I'm gonna get my hands on this game
well yeah man let's see if we can get
that engagement up eighteen hundred
percent boys that was validating I'll be
honest yeah that didn't feel good I was
so nervous about the actual stuff from
the game oh oh yeah
like okay this it's all silly and you
know like with the with the ad and
everything but like the corridor video
that's the real ad that's the real song
adding a real favor here so thank you
yeah for sure that's awesome to help me
sleep at night as well your game
deserves it oh hey Peter well well we
have you here I want to ask you about
another
um idea we have um okay we have this
idea to go out and
have so that the title is professional
VFX artists make Street portraits for
random people
um so we want to go out to like a park
next week and
um and and do caricatures with willing
participants so we do like a scan and
then we we edit the scanner like put it
in an environment yeah and then give
them and then give them the render like
the image run you know that sounds great
everybody loves art where they're the
subject like you see people on the
subway drawing people and they give it
to them and it always makes their day
right yeah we go into the subway with
laptops
we're all staring at one person yes
hey dude not in L.A dude
we could do it on the light rail
we're leaving without our laptops if
that's the case no Christian will
Christian will be security dude no we
have plenty of Airsoft guns we'll just
like drape them over our bodies oh yeah
just addresses John Wick yeah so we want
to do that next week yeah let's do it
okay okay cool cool I think we're gonna
need to bring like a generator or a
solar array though because the laptop's
not going to last long enough on the
batteries yeah yeah I'm a little worried
about even seeing the laptop when we're
out there you know I've I don't think
I've ever successfully seen a laptop
screen outside oh sure you know what I
mean yeah I'm thinking we bring a tent
hey stranger real quick
[Laughter]
can anyone post up on Venice and like
sell street art and stuff they're
probably gonna they're probably gonna
tell you you can't I think you need
permits for that really which is why we
should go to Hollenbeck park because
Colin Beck Park is very chill we've
filmed videos in there one we filmed a
video in there where we had a wrestling
ring set up and a man and nothing but a
wrestling Speedo
and we had like three cameras and we
were we were in there all day and the
cops drove by it never released it was
called um
it was like WWE moves in IRL
sounds weird yeah it didn't it didn't
disappointing strangers yeah the
execution didn't quite meet the idea so
that's why we canned it but yeah
um but the point is we filmed in there
all day cops drove by people walked by
it was very relaxed people didn't mind
so that's a really good spot to do it
and there's always people there
okay well a question about permits I
feel like if your permanent looks
official enough they're not going to
call anyone to like see if it's legit no
at least not for like an hour yeah yeah
yeah so I advise you enough time yeah
I'm just wondering like you need a place
with a decent amount of foot traffic not
like a lot but enough to where you can
finally get a couple of people no I'm
telling you Hollenbeck Park in the
afternoon is people go there after work
and stuff and it's okay it's it's nice
and Serene and it's it's pretty relaxing
and there's always people there it's a
good spot cool it'll work and it's right
by the studio that sounds super fun
let's do it yeah
okay sounds good all right well am I
gonna am I gonna reuse some of those
assets from the mobile games
check out Peter's Peters check out
Peter's game
um join the Instagram now so you know
when it comes out and um we'll all be
playing it uh so anyways Peter thanks
for being a good support with all this
yeah man thank you thank you bro this is
so fun thank you what am I gonna say no
whatever you guys were gonna make was
gonna be amazing and in case I haven't
said it enough yet that what you did
make is insane and amazing thank you
brother it's a work of art like I
seriously think it needs a LACMA exhibit
it is truly insane that's for sure yeah
thank you really insane pretty good all
right are you ready I'm gonna I'm gonna
play us out let's do it all right all
right
[Music]
foreign
I'm wondering when that solo album's
coming out yeah seriously he needs one
next year guys next year
see you later bye